ESPN with the express written consent of
the NFL presents the 34:30 documentary
ejaculate stunning charge the
billionaire owner of the New England
Patriots Robert Kraft caught up in a
sexting in South Florida soliciting
prostitution Robert Kraft paid a
prostitute human trafficking paying for
and receiving sex he was twice
videotaped a billionaire flew from
Boston to Jupiter Florida jerked off by
some 40-something woman in a strip mall
hours before the AFC Championship game
that can't even imagine the sick he
was doing for the division around him
portraits is pretty filthy but it's the
second nice to Jack Shaq and Jupiter
probably wouldn't go there if it weren't
so close to my favorite liquor store to
go well you too shall fade down zones
each inside the pill son by level but
this boils down to is human sex
trafficking the New England Patriots
support human sex trafficking
I've had it up to here
Spygate deflategate Aaron Hernandez
Russell Wilson throwing the Super Bowl
and now Bob Kraft rub-and-tug Boston
doesn't want the Patriots anymore I hope
he sells the team to okay see you were
six rings and said things like I'm the
Patriots owner Robert Kraft which real
easy to identify him because I'm a
Dolphins fan people are gonna call me a
hater you're right I hate human sex
trafficking I also hate the people in
New England but not as much as I hate
human sex trafficking before the massage
he insisted the masseuse kissed his
championship rings
Bam Bam Bam can balls on that
that's all I don't shoot magic about
show Mia I went go Renshaw hating and I
go crap and I got to his office fully
prepared to suckas
mr. craft wasn't able to achieve an
erection until the sex worker put on a
Tom Brady Jersey as I stated in my
report it wasn't a firm erection it was
more like a raw chicken tender gummy
warm Wow some couch underneath in
Chennai I am a season ticket holder
thrown away
I feel like I have been paying for these
hand jobs well Union boy one dog hiding
yeah the way though
yoshino sure you don't want to go in the
room at the rabo crack it smells like
something died in his balls human sex
trafficking I think God we didn't get
audio it bothered me a lot more a long
time ago now after 17 years of it
I have healthy boundaries the last 20
years have been forever tainted might as
well give back the rings at least we got
our chowder in the socks down at the
hall but with the wicked Matt Damon Sam
Adams do when you come to Florida look
at our alligators enjoy our space
program but don't jizz on victims of
human sex trafficking I lost my family
I'll tell you who really got jerked off
that day every young football fan I mean
the roundabout way Bob Kraft jerked off
children that's his legacy
next week on thirty four thirty what if
I told you Mark Wahlberg spent 45 days
in prison for robbing and blinding a
Vietnamese man Derek Jeter presents Mark
Wahlberg did a hate crime
you